and no and i love it and everybody loves
it and you don't have to be in the in
crowd to get it you know anybody can get
it and that's what i love about and i i
think that you invigorated comedy
central comedy central itself i don't
think there's
anything that uh maybe south park and
the roasts are the two things that
people think about when they think about
comedy central so cultural perennial
moments yeah and those are the moments
and whether you're poking fun at
donald trump or bieber or bieber was he
good was he good uh bieber was a rare a
rare time when
you know because i'm on all those talent
calls for years it was one of the one
times where bieber called us really
scooter braun his manager said
justin wants to get and i'd mentioned it
to justin one other time or something
but he was
he had a big album he had a great album
that hadn't come out they knew they had
something great but they had a pr issue
right and justin's talked about this and
scooters talked about this and justin
has personally
thanked me for this moment
because
he had just gotten arrested he gotten in
trouble for different dumb
teenage [ __ ] right stuff you do when
you're 19 20 21 and you got all the
money in the world
and
he needed like a reset like a re like
when your internet's out and you got to
turn it off for a minute and turn it
back on that's what he needed he needed
to own it all
and do something where he accepts
responsibility by taking the jokes
taking them well and then having a
really good funny
self-aware
sincere rebuttal right and that by
design i took him out we you know we
went out for lunch we practiced like we
really cared
and he volunteered to be roasted he
really wanted it did you help him write
his rebuttal we did the team did yeah i
did i wanted to i heard the sincere part
he ran
and i've never told this before but
i didn't want to hear his jokes i wanted
because i knew i trusted the team to
take care of him with the comedy i
wanted to hear his
owning it
maya culpa's not the right word but i
wanted to hear him own his
childhood his juvenile behavior and then
man up and i worked on him on that part
he had it handwritten
in a notebook no handlers no publicist
he really did it from the heart he
really can write
and
then he wanted to talk about me he said
jeff are you seeing anybody you'd be a
great father like he was a very sincere
beyond his years
and i think the roast really like did
that for him i think so that was his
comeback
i think that was his comeback i said
justin everyone's been pointing their
fingers at you lately but that's mostly
just lesbians telling the barber how
they want their hair done
that's brilliant
[Music]
you